I don't hate guys who are big losers and
have guts Burn
it into your eyes I'm Zahad's princess Ultimately you won't even be able to make eye contact Do
you know where to go?
Is a god ok Let's start
mature
google Say 4
Don't show off in a playful place
Hahahaha Don't come with a teaching weapon or this device Don't
even know who your opponent is Princess
[music]
Big hole technique  I learned it, it
makes sense
[music]
This is the answer you chose
Good
point is that I can't adjust the world tax I shouldn't
You're made by cafe water noodles, right?
I'll kick you in seconds The
world isn't
fair, you know When we're being robbed, we act like we don't know The moment we
try to rob you, you get in the way
I've never risked my life to stand up against it It's
always been a blast since I was robbed It
looks like it's about time to hand over the badge I'm
out of breath Princess
I wonder if it
was a life without quarrels, but
yeah
If I faced it, wouldn't my heart be between my legs like it is now?
It's
not just life that keeps going A
good man is ruined
[Music]
Ah
, it's a sin to end up with a princess, isn't
it?  Baby,
here's my bowl
and your badge is here
10 minutes
[music]